the real world we are as we know or
middle of the pandemic as well and any
time we see a sport saying we're gonna
give this a whirl and then it comes back
and you see it and even though there's
no fans it's like ok I I kind of like it
and what we've seen over the first round
and a half of the charles schwab
challenge who's in the clubhouse right
now Christopher right now oh right now
Harold Parker
Harold runner ok and to talk about all
this is our friend from and be seeing
the Golf Channel David Feherty back here
on the show how are you David
very well Richie thank you for having me
on
it's good to see actual players playing
competitive guy look I loved the Brady
and Peyton and Phil and Tiger and I
loved the the Dustin Johnson and Rory I
mean and the rest of the guys getting
back together you know but to me this is
the real deal this is exciting this is
fun right yeah I thought it was great I
was sort of expecting
like you was gonna have to see any kind
of golf you know what the other stuff
but this was much better than much more
enjoyable and I expected it to be
why so well just the golf was so good I
mean I thought these guys came back with
a vengeance just you know ready to play
and I guess this means that they've
they've been working on their games lopa
David Wright well enough time like three
times the length of the normal winter
break and III think it's really you know
I think it's done marvels for jordan
Spieth for example you know he played
beautiful yesterday yeah he also came
out a house of fire earlier today he was
40 birdied four of his first nine it was
pretty it looked pretty good and then
you got a little bit of a double bogey
there what do you make of this is the
thing that all my friends were we're
talking about certainly last night when
we were we're all chatting Bryson to
Shambo look it looks like he he spent
some time in a weight room during his
quarantine yeah oh yeah yeah look at his
the change that he's had over the last
18 months um I'm not sure how much
weight he's put on but it's pretty much
all muscle
and he you know he saw analytical about
everything it's you know it's it's the
right muscles he's developing as well
yeah I mean how do you think that's
going to what is what is the whole point
of bulking up if you're if you're a
golfer David well I mean he's just his
swing is the type of swing that you know
you can get more weight behind it if if
you look at his driving statistics he's
put on about I think close to 30 yards
certainly you know like 25 yards in the
last 18 months and that makes a huge
difference that's two clubs or a club
and a half these days and you know if
you you know take take that away you
know if you're going with 9-iron instead
of seven or something like that
something that's a huge difference yeah
I mean Rory McIlroy's 8-under on the day
right now he is just firing it pins and
Varner is is sitting in the clubhouse
what do you know about this kid Varner
he's one of the most popular kids out
there you got a terrific sense of humor
really smart and a terrific young player
and a great character really just he's a
joy to be around
well one of the things that we we we
definitely took out of the two events
for charity that we saw again headlined
by one on NBC in the family of networks
with Dustin Johnson and Rory McIlroy and
that kid wolf and obviously Ricky Fowler
and Tom and Phil and tiger and Peyton's
being miked up but do you think that
maybe some of the players would be
wouldn't be mind being miked up sort of
like an NFL player during these
competitions with old fans David you
know and I with no fans I think it's a
terrific idea
actually even with fans you know I've
always been kind of in favor of maybe
not the players but the caddies you know
so that you get that interaction you
know between the quite often it's more
important what the caddie says and you
know you'd get the peripheral you know
audio or round it as well I think it's
certainly something worth thinking about
yeah I guess
you just I don't know if it just affects
your swing or affects anything your
concentration if you feel those battery
packs and where Rickie Fowler's the only
one who's agreed to do it this week
Chris so what you're saying yeah that's
okay so it looks like some at least
somebody's gonna be attempting to do it
I just don't know if it it might be too
much of a distraction for somebody David
yeah well the equipment is so it's so
small these days I remember one of the
early skins games that I did done in
Mexico I had to hit a shot with the you
know the headset and the the waist pack
you know hold on and other recreate one
of Jack Nicklaus bunker shots no
pressure there
and I claimed shanked it and her lady
shins it was it was horrific but the
stuff is you know it just improved so
much over the years it's not it's just a
little sort of a 2 by 3 pack you know on
one wire you know so I don't really see
that being a problem I'll be good what
do you think of cap cos mustache David
what do you think of Brooks coming out
of the coming out of quarantine with you
know sort of the nose furniture sort of
a 70s porno mustache I was gonna go Burt
Reynolds you know like that that's the
this that but yeah I mean just coming
out like that and just you know hand on
a hip just with that sort of steel glare
I mean that's that's a that's a
statement don't you think maybe things
people won't recognize him I'm not sure
hmm I guess we'll know we'll know again
I mentioned this the other day we'll
know if everybody is just gonna be chill
and I know that the competition is
competition but we take so many things
for granted in this world right and that
that now the sport is back and we're
seeing it that maybe we're a little bit
more laid back we'll know if it's the
most laid-back
situation if kept cos standing in the
middle of the fairway and bryson to
shambo's on his 18th look it's something
that's inside the leather and kept cos
like I don't care
you know like one more like no would be
more laid-back that's for sure but you
know one of the things I think is sort
of an advantage to the new players the
only golf that we've seen on television
like this is college golf you know where
you get the kids out there and there
just aren't very many people around so
you know some of the you know the new
recruits from the corn claret or
whatever maybe you know they may have a
little edge there or you know be a
little more at home than some of the
established players so walk me through
all were you watching this stuff over
the weekend David do you've got a man
caved you got the situation set up I
mean what does it look like to watch
golf with David Feherty David well I'm a
bit of a germaphobe so you know with the
president situation you know the whole
lot I actually watch in a full-length
condom even even when I'm in my house
you know so it's kind of hard to
communicate with me but you know I think
man has mattress for about the last four
months yeah and at this time of the year
at NBC we wouldn't be doing much anyway
sure you know but watching TV with me
especially watching golf it's not a
particularly athletic endeavor shall we
say so I mean dude are you a talker do
you eat something or you what do you
what do you what do you got going on
David well you know with the six feet
apart thing great difficulty keeping six
feet between me and the refrigerator and
okay and my my two new pals are Ben and
Gary yeah so so yeah there's generally
some mastication going on excellent use
of mastication David just fantastic you
know what that means Chris you know what
that means I don't I'm looking it up
right means he's eating
yeah there's just a zone you're talking
over them but I I got it I got that
let's straight ahead David thank you for
the time really appreciate it always
enjoy our chats big time and enjoy
watching the live golf and I look
forward to chatting more with you very
soon yeah thank you buddy anytime right
back at you know I enjoyed being on your
show David Feherty keep doing home in
homes with each other NBC Sports and
Golf Channel Alice right here on the
Rich Eisen show
hey you watched all the way to the end
thanks for that watch more right here